[Applause]
this was the moment uganda's
anti-homosexuality bill was passed into
law
despite being watered down the new laws
are amongst the harshest in the world
when you cut out acts of homosexuality
through Force
or duress or a new influence
then the law defines that as aggravated
homosexuality and what is the punishment
the maximum punishment is death
activists say they'll fight to have the
law repealed so when they're making law
the public has to really be involved
especially people are concerned about we
saw during the hearings of the committee
and during the times that it was at a
discussion that not even a single LGB
type person was basically before the
committee to have their views hard and
this is this is a law that affects them
directly
same-sex relations were already illegal
in Uganda as they are in more than 30
African countries and activists say the
new law goes further in targeting the
LGBT community and other countries are
looking to follow suit we see that the
more states are sponsoring these bills
this hateful legislations the more the
LGBT communities is impacted and also
that effect as well you know how other
politicians and other countries are are
following suits so yeah this bill as is
signed now into law by President
museveni is is having real consequences
on the lgbtq individuals in Uganda but
also across the region
the US UK and EU have condemned the new
measures while leading Health agencies
have warned it could set back the fight
against HIV AIDS U.N agencies say it
will prevent gay people from seeking
education and treatments for the disease
for fear of their Safety and Security
Barbara angerpa Al Jazeera